hello and welcome to this video playing
Grand Master SWAT italic let's see what
is playing here tough opponent Jeremih
rating as suffer to being quite clearly
below 2400 and always feels kind of
wrong at least at least to me so I'm
playing a classical Queens gambit and
see what he what is doing this line ok
never quite understood what riders
aiming for him so you shooting form some
c 5 t 5 or I don't never got this ok so
this is really the idea ok no if I
wasn't aware that this is the idea so
let's take and see if this is really and
using clear anything serious might be
here this takes bishop down c4 hmm
doesn't feel very comfortable ok still
let's do this
and you're not going to take Queen c-4
would surprise me should be should be
six looks very okay okay so this one
preparing Bocchetti six I don't see how
I can I don't think I can play without
this move which is kind of ugly I fully
understand but I still didn't see how I
cannot do it okay um alright it's got
this night night coming around to see
four and so on okay
not sure how bad it is I mean he's got
more activity that's clear word I'm not
so easily falling those queenside pawns
okay probably not good I can't maybe
night over here how to do that Knight to
c6 is probably a good spot and keeping
keeping this attacked a five attacked
yeah why does better my pawns are
somewhat devalued but I have to have to
defend and see what happens I can bring
this up this should have six not sure if
this is a helpful move could weaken the
c5 pawn quite a bit
I have at the moment you more suspicious
is also gone yeah so i guess i can at
least go down ok taking it's not a great
idea what is he trying book a3 b3 maybe
okay I'm interesting
not not very nice this is just to be
five it looks entirely wrong anyway if I
cannot spend even more time
hmm ok count on 2 K 3 mm
but if I take this and go on I 2d6 is
that so bad then 96 I'm not so sure
about this if I get the King to c7 for
example this is relatively this is quite
okay in terms of protection named Martin
to go eat fire but if I can threaten to
enter myself there maybe this is still
kind of playable
ok over over to c6 again I have to
really change change my plan see all
over again yeah I think the worst is
probably over even though I don't quite
see how to really make use of all that
him 94 doesn't really feel like I i
gained much I just choose six or what or
this one this is this is making some
sense lock him a little bit here
94 I guess oh it's real and barca just
running there Wow hmm didn't see that
one coming so much
manche I really don't like that and I
was kind of out of it again and then I
played it badly again the worst was
definitely over Jack racking f6 is
probably winning for white ok that's
what's disappointing he really left me
back into the game and I didn't take
this opportunity that's always a bit of
a shame ok black resides you know around
here i have no problem whatsoever i'm in
fact i'm clearly better of course yeah
engine gives you five and wind and winds
for black yeah i just played that very
very badly clearly age five is just this
is a bad idea that this was good then my
divorce also better for black there's
just a terrible idea I look t4 is so
good for black I played that I hated so
badly that's it i was simply sleeping
and i did did not did not did not think
at all and all of a sudden and lose him
not very good it was so bad
yeah I think I defended this worst
position and actually pretty well and
then you completely over play this hand
here this was pretty pretty terrible see
form and also totally unnecessary you
just weekends this position a lot kg5
was already decisive I cannot take a lot
keep us materially anymore if you place
something like this I'm taking this and
just just start to win stuff here yes no
he is full of bigness assume oh I how
badly i did play that h5 I wanted to
freeze them in the King subway 90 form
they played slowly in a way there was
such a bad idea and ok yeah I can
readjust but here it gets it's just
worse now awful very awful oh my god
thanks for watching